landing a synergy attack can even stun
stronger enemies and bosses when
performed at the right time Yass
stunning
I am your complimentary upgrade I'm
Lorraine and I'm your first-class hot
towel I'm like scissors my dear show we
talk about the most vacation is stuff in
the Marvel Universe totally a word it's
summertime so we are getting ready for
the ultimate nerd vacation that's right
y'all it's time for San Diego comic-con
2019 we will be there on the ground with
Marvel live yeah we're gonna be bringing
you everything from Marvel's biggest
stars to comic book creators to the
world's best cosplay all weekend long
yes hey make sure you join us when we
kick off Thursday at 11 a.m. Pacific
time and live stream every day and day
through Sunday it is a marathon not a
sprint
you're a favorite thing about comic-con
Oh Lorraine what a tough question I love
the stage event I got to say I love the
cosplay competition seeing all the ideas
y'all come up with four different
characters I remember we had smarter man
in the Spider Buster armor and then he
was wearing a spider-man mask on you the
spider-man helmet the reveal was great
we all cheered that is just it's perfect
oh my goodness what about you Larry I
have to say my favorite things are
actually people which are the fans we
get to talk to the fans all the time but
it's so nice to get to have people talk
to us and you just won't be walking in
the hallway and be like I like your
shirt I like your shirt are we best
friends we're best friends
I have lifelong friends from comic-con
you will tell you going booth to you'll
have a magical adventure it's gonna be
great and they make sure you tune in on
July 18th through the 21st on marvel.com
and across all of Marvel's social media
I'm so excited I'm not gonna sleep until
the very day of Comic Con no one will
need you to know I can't you'll lose
your mind okay that's not the only big
thing happening next week right the
Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the Black
Order is coming to the Nintendo switch
on July 19th let's wait y'all yeah yeah
yeah which is why I've got the download
on what you need to know before you play
the game to the gaming lounge yeah here
are five things that you need to know
about Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the
black order before you get the game on
July 19th
unlock your potential each character has
up to four abilities which unlock as
each character reaches a certain level
hot tip use experience cubes as a quick
way to unlock your favorite characters
full potential next up team up with
timing characters can amplify their
abilities by synergizing with another
teammate who has a compatible ability
hot tip landing a synergy attack can not
only lead to greater damage but can even
stun stronger enemies and bosses when
performed at the right time yeah done
they get it team up your team's you
don't need to pick four characters of
the same team to gain a team bonus just
having two or three from the same team
can boost your team hot tip be sure to
experiment with various team
combinations to find the right set of
bonuses that work best for you teamwork
makes the dream work don't be afraid to
be passive-aggressive let me explain
that each character has either passive
or active abilities that make them
unique from each other experiment with
each character as their unique ability
may be what you need to clear that hard
to beat challenge
hot tip Hulk has attack armor which
allows him to blow through enemy attacks
while Wolverines healing factor allows
him to recover vitality when idling go
extreme in your boss battles Alliance
extreme attacks are your character
strongest ability using them at the
right time against a boss is the
quickest way to stagger them or to do
big damage hot tip choose wisely between
the two Alliance extreme attacks during
boss battles to increase your chances of
victory and there you have it go
preorder Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the
black order now so that you can play it
on Nintendo switch starting on July 19
I know ooh-whoo he freezes sometimes I
know what I'm gonna do with my summer
though I'm gonna be playing Marvel
Ultimate Alliance through the Black
Order baby oh yeah I will be with you
yeah please be sure to pre-order the
game now or get it in stores on July
19th oh it looks so fun I am gonna smash
the crap out of Proxima midnight you
know what you did you're dead to me OOP
okay yeah well it's an eight life can't
all be fun and games unless you're
writing pen a ghost aka agent M who does
nothing but have fun and play games I
know in fact he even got to swing by
Marvel Studios and learn about how
spider-man far from home whips off the
screen I'll check it
[Music]
hey Marvel fans Bryan Pena Jose ka agent
M here gonna give you a little bit of a
behind-the-scenes chat and a look at
spider-man far from home but I'm not
doing that alone
I've got 3d stereoscopic supervisor Evan
Jacobs here so you're the guy who helps
us get spider-man to flip off the screen
that's exactly right like that that's
pretty cool a lot of people a lot of our
fans let's say go see the movie more
than once and so this is like a way to
go you saw it in 2d that first night but
you go back the second night or the
third night or whatever and you see it
in 3d and you go oh my god it's like
seeing a new movie one of the things I
want to dig into is like just the
biology of it all how does that affect
the work that you and your team is well
if if you think about it we experience
the world in 3d all the time right with
our two eyes taking the world in and our
brain is taking those two separate
images and fusing them and giving you
and I what we call depth perception when
you go to the movies for many years it's
been flat which in a weird way is what
people have come to think is normal 3d
in the cinema though is a little bit
different than 3d in real life and that
it's actually a magic trick of sorts but
we're gonna trick your brain into
thinking that things are have dimension
and depth but at the end of the day you
put those glasses on and hopefully it
feels like spider-man's right there with
you you know in the trailer for
spider-man far from home we saw this
like water creature we saw the big fire
monster sort of destroying the bridge
and like all these these things that
Spiderman is up against of all the fun
elements and play in spider-man far from
home I would imagine the most is
spider-man himself because he's
spider-man he's the greatest superhero
of all time well it what's cool about
him is he does a lot more flying around
in this movie so there's a lot of fun
opportunites
anytime we can get him airborne and and
you know or shooting webs or whatever
this you know there's a lot of those are
always great because he can bring the
audience on the ride with you I want to
talk a little bit about rotoscoping yeah
because much fun what is rotoscoping in
terms of the stereoscopic experience
the basic idea is tracing photographed
images right if you think about what 3d
is in the context of a movie you sort of
start with this flat image that would be
sitting right on the screen and then you
want some of the things to be identified
as distant background some in mid-ground
some in the foreground and to do that
with a flat 2d image that you
photographed I'm gonna trace the whole
thing so you trace every single thing in
the frame that you want to have on a
different layer that's how you separate
these people right that's the first step
of this process and that's what we call
rotoscoping there's a procedural process
that would maybe take the edges and
stretch them out but that doesn't look
very good so pretty quickly you've got
to go in and hand paint all that stuff
so you're rotoscoping the entire film
every single frame every yeah I'm trying
to process yeah like the the amount of
people that you need the manpower that
I'm the attention to detail because it's
not a you know the way you describe it
it doesn't seem like something just
someone like puts a headphones on and
blindly does it no it is it is it's a
it's a crazy process but it's you know
one of the things that's really fun
about it is when you get a filmmaker in
at the end of the thing and you've done
a sequence and you've taken their film
and and presenting it back to them in a
completely new way and then they react
you know as if as if they've never seen
the movie yeah that's really fun one of
the things that I think is you know
differentiates the Marvel films from
some of the other films that are out
there in the marketplace that are
released in 3d is that we're really
involved all the way through I heard a
term as we were starting to put this
together something called a depth script
yeah what is the depth script and how
does that play into this whole process
if you think about it 3d can be just
like a musical score or just about any
other part of a film in that in that you
you essentially have a depth script and
you sort of can be like I can make it
very deep in this section because it's
going to be very exciting 3d moment and
then I can give the eye the audience a
break and you know come down a little
bit and then I go back up again for
something else and that kind of ebb and
flow of the of the process is a creative
control that we have
so that people experience it so if you
think about it just in the musical
context if he just kept it loud all the
time you wouldn't really know that it
was loud you know you're not always
doing the cool 3d just to do it yeah
you're doing it if it affects them if it
helps them yeah Evan I'm super excited
to see the movie you have completely
sold me here on this whole conversation
but for our fans who you know I've seen
it once maybe haven't seen it in 3d yet
why do they have to see it in 3d it's a
completely different experience than TV
so the elementals are incredible there's
some other stuff I can't talk about
that's amazing what and really really
fun and disorienting and cool and
exciting and it's gonna get take we're
gonna take them on a ride so the it's
definitely I'm very proud of this movie
and I'm proud of the work that we did
there's some of the films that we work
on really lend themselves to the format
and this is one of those films without
avoiding spoilers I can't tell you much
about it but you got to go see it I'm
telling you the cameras are off you can
tell me everything okay there you have
it everybody and thank you so much I am
a full convert into the 3d experience I
need it I want it I hope you guys want
it too spider-man far from home is in
theaters now be sure to see it in
through oh so good I love spider-man in
3d especially because spider-man by
virtue of being spider-man is always
swinging through the buildings not so
cool in 3d yeah and I gotta say all the
visual effects in every single frame
just going through every single frame
and doing all these minor adjustments in
minor tweak day thank you that VFX team
so good someone get these people coffee
oh my goodness that's a lot of work you
know I'm gonna I think I'm gonna take a
European vacation myself like Spidey I'm
just not gonna fight anyone don't try to
make me it's my vacation I'm looking for
the fights
I wanna play some badniks oh oh yeah
listen hey tell us where in the Marvel
Universe
you think we make the best vacation spot
and use the hashtag Earth's Mightiest
show oh and this is cool this week and
Marvel has revealed some of the Marvel
merch available exclusively at San Diego
comic-con go head over there and watch
that video now on Marvel calm I'm
Langston I'm Lorraine this is Marvel
your universe
thanks for watching our Smita show if
you like this like this leave us a
comment and subscribe to the Marvel
channel or click the box over there to
watch our last episode so we're in the
Marvel Universe do you want to go I
think I just want to do a little
staycation maybe dr. strange place nice
is it